[Music]
with a very special piece of information
regarding my latest short film cardboard
warfare 2 I'm in thrall to announce the
cardboard warfare 2 beginning it's very
own premiere a very special premiere I
might ask now let's get down to the
business the premiere will be held at 7
p.m. at the area that you want to aurora
Cineplex in Roswell Georgia the others
okay now admission is $10 I know what
you're saying
Glenn ten dollars is way too expensive
for a 25 minute movie chuckle I'd have
to agree with you but it's $10 too
expensive for the red carpet experience
photos with cast and crew the screening
of card warfare won one point by them
too along with the Q&A panel t-shirts
posters the signings giveaways of
rabbits special guest appearance by Joel
F garden olan Rogers Jim Chandler Jim's
son Zack sale brent Zaffino David
Galloway and Brett dryer and that sounds
like a deal son but fret not for those
of you who can't make it to the occasion
cardboard warfare 2 movie posted YouTube
shortly after the premiere now the link
to buy your tickets is in the
description below
tickets are selling fast and there's a
limited quantity so buy your ticket down
see you guys there does that mean I'm a
zipline believe it was
[Music]
you